we're gonna take a call next from Andy
and Missouri hey Andy your question for
dr. D hey hey hey there I have two
teenage boys 15 and 13 our 15 year old
has passed me up height-wise thanks
heaven yes he's got a jars permit ins
last year and he suffers from what we
call teen brain it seems to be like a
close cousin to the know-it-all teenager
my 13 year old quite hasn't got there
yet they're very quick yes he will he's
catching on quick to what he's learning
from that's right that's right how do I
can bet said teen brain while also
getting my or our point across and also
locking to still feel I'm some I did and
not being hurt by you know timing called
carbonyl puffing I think it's real clear
and real quick and real easy and you set
boundaries you're the parent you're the
dad this is your home I think it's
always good facts or your friends being
real clear about here's when you drive
my car and my house and in my
neighborhood it's gonna be done like
this I think there's a lot of folks
parents today that want to be friends
with their kids that want to buddy up to
their kids and what kids are craving is
boundaries they are craving boundaries
they're craving somebody to say this is
the line that says as far as you go and
this is how much I love you because I'm
gonna hold the line here and so having a
16 year olds may be the funnest
adventure you've ever had and it's gonna
if you're not balding already it's
coming so congratulations to you like I
said too late well they could have come
back and they're not coming back but I
I've seen it over and over especially I
say especially all kids all teenage kids
crave crave boundaries Andy be the dad
that loves her kids and give it to him
give it to him direct you know and just
you know I we had I remember hours we we
had a
I heard a guy say this one time and
actually ended up using it on one of my
mouthy daughters I walked in the kitchen
and she was she was just drench was just
yelling at her mother mmm and I'm like
wait a minute stop you might talk to
your mother that way but no one talks to
my wife that way that's right I will
take you out and make another one looks
just like you I mean you are not doing
that
and that all that is is like you know no
that is not even a possibility that's
going down as you said in this house
right you know and so and then the other
one we would always do is just listen
and trapped inside of every teenage
bodies a four-year-old and a 34 year old
and I just asked them which one am I
talking to right now like if you're
talking up to a 34 year old I'll talk to
you like a 34 year old we'll have a
conversation I'll persuade you like one
of my friends that this is a wise set of
principles to operate your life on if
you're gonna be a four year old I'm just
gonna tell you what to frickin do and
you're gonna do it because I'm like
because I'm in charge here that's great
I'm gonna I'm gonna mess this up a
little bit there's an old Mark Twain
quote that said when I was 14 my old man
was the dumbest guy I'd ever met in my
life and when I came home at 21 I was
stunned at how much he had learned in
seven years right so you're entering the
season where it's natural they're gonna
want to they're gonna want to pull away
they're gonna want to show you how big
and tough especially the one that's
bigger than you I think some some
practical tips involve them be a dad who
says I'm sorry when you do something
that's not right honor your wife honor
your community they are gonna watch and
learn right you can say everything you
want to they're gonna learn how to go to
the next step their life by watching how
you live your life Andy so it's
important that you model the steps that
you want them to take